Because you can either win or
learn in a Design Sprint,
your next steps are going to vary.
Now, it's likely that you' receive
feedback from users about how they used
the product, and what they didn't like.
In this case, you'll need to reconsider
some user flows or you might need to
make some small adjustments in the user
interface, such as clarifying user
actions or making particular buttons and
links more prominent.
If you received critical feedback
about the value proposition or
if users are not clear in what
they can do with the product,
then you should revisit
the original idea.
You might alter the original idea or
validate that the product
solves the user's problem.
Entrepreneurs see these moments
as learning opportunities.
So don't feel like this type
of moment is a setback.
If you receive mostly positive feedback,
then you need to monitor metrics and
continue to improve your product.
As you get more feedback on the product,
you can add more features and
fine-tune the user experience.
You'll see examples of this and
learn about metrics in the next lesson.